all right this is a video um that
explains the new
rechargeable booster and pepper panic
saga
you can see it here it's below the
regular um
the regular boosters that you buy
this one can be recharged
over and over throughout a level and it
says here you can see that we have to
explode 15 more peppers to charge it up
so i picked a level that's easy to
explode peppers in this is level 95
and it actually makes levels like this a
lot easier which you'll see later um
so this is a match patterns level i'm
going to kind of follow along
you know from watching our other guides
that when you do this you want to look
for the other matches the future matches
first so you don't mess them up but i
don't see any um
l-shaped matches which is going to be
the next one anyway so i'm going to go
ahead and make this
for pepper match here and i'm just going
to try to look to explode peppers and
start a panic as fast as possible
so i'm looking around for you know big
matches and shockwave matches
right now
um
the um
the booster is it's pretty
straightforward what it does is it makes
a match and
it fills in the in the space for a match
that you can't make at the time
and that's why it's you know
particularly helpful on match patterns
here's our l so we'll go ahead and use
that
and this will likely
um get a lot of things going i don't
know if it'll start a panic this time
but we should be able to start it right
now i'm gonna look around real quick see
if i see the gap for the five match i
don't see that
so we'll go ahead and try to start a
panic
now you can see the bar on the booster
every time a pepper explodes it fills up
and when we get to 15 it'll give us a
little
indication there that it's ready
as it is now i mean they just released
it in the last episode release
episode 28
i have a feeling that it'll um
they'll update that little graphic there
so
right now we need a five pepper match
and um i'm not really so concerned about
that at the moment
um
instead i'm just going to
look for a spot where i can you know
make a match
this um
we do have the gap for the five there so
i'll just go ahead and do this and see
what happens
all right so
um
so what you do is you click on this
and you can pick a pepper
all right um
say if we put it right here uh even
though we can move that over it will
give us the yellow one in that spot and
it'll make a four pepper match um
it has to be a match that you make at
the time like you can't just say oh i
can make my five pepper match if i turn
this one yellow
um
if you see you click there nothing
happens um it has to be one that will be
an actual match at the time
so um
let me go ahead and clear off this five
peppermints first and then we'll
then we'll use that
i'm just looking for the gap real quick
i don't see it again
let's see
there we go okay well it's not going to
stay i guess
but um
let's see here
all right i'm just going to show you
this because the panic is going to start
anyways and then we'll be recharged
again so even though let's pretend this
wasn't here if i needed a 4 pepper match
or i need to make a shock wave i can put
it on this blue or this green pepper and
then it's going to give me a blue one
see how it makes that match for me
that's essentially how it works um
let's start a panic and you'll see it'll
start to charge up again
and then it'll be ready to go after this
pair because we're going to get 15
explosions in the process
so you know it can be useful in um
it can be useful in situations where you
need an explosion
need to
make a particular match
um maybe you need to collect a certain
color
it's really helpful the way and it just
was released but it's you know it's
retroactive throughout the game so even
in the early levels you'll have this so
this actually is a pretty big game
changer it'll make things a lot easier
especially in some of those levels that
people have traditionally been stuck on
um
you know you can use it anywhere at any
time like here i don't you know let's
just pretend i need an l match well i
can put it on this green one
it'll give me a red one and i'll get my
l-shape match
so that's basically how it works you can
use it anywhere at any time as long as
it's charged up right here it says
explode 15 more so like if i explode i
don't know if it's going to start to
panic but
as they explode
you know it'll tell you how many left
you have to go if you don't get it like
we'll get it here but
you know it it's a little bit hard the
the only problem i had with it is it's a
little bit hard to see
and when it's you know so having played
this game for
400 plus levels at this point
it is
i'm not used to using it yet
so
sometimes i forget but um
you know for new players this will be
great because you'll know how to use it
right away and you know basically you'll
be able to
move through the game a little faster
this is another instance where this is
here but i need a t so i'll put it there
it'll give me the orange one that i need
and
now i have um
my match
the um
the other thing is there's two possible
matches
which i won't probably run into on this
board so much
but when there are twos
you know there's no way to say which one
it's going to give you
so that can be a little bit frustrating
when you need one color and the other
color comes instead
but overall it's a great feature it
definitely makes the game more user
friendly for players
if you have any questions about it be
sure to leave a comment below
and i'll i'll let you know see how it
says right now i blew up two so now it
says i have 13 more to go so it keeps
track for you
but yeah if you have any questions be
sure to leave a comment on the video or
visit our site and leave a comment there
come to our group we have close to 8 000
members now so if you aren't a member
and you love this game it's probably
something you'd want to do
make sure you like the video if you find
it useful
and i'll be making more soon thanks